this video is currently sponsored by
keeps more on them later on
hey 42 here scotland's a funny old place
isn't it
a land where the sea word is used as a
term of endearment
where an awful filled sack made of
sheep's stomach is considered a great
delicacy and where the national animal
doesn't even exist those who venture
north of the wall a hadrian's wall that
is will find themselves in a land of
crumbling castles missed shrouded
valleys and murky locks
where large shapes shift beneath the
surface of the inky waters
what they might also find if they were
to make a small detour to the village of
milton just outside of dunbarton is a
mysterious gothic bridge where dogs keep
trying to kill themselves for reasons
that nobody can explain
owners describe their dogs freezing on
the spot midway across this particular
bridge before apparently being possessed
by some kind of strange energy
which compels them to leap to their
deaths
that may sound quite hard to believe but
this isn't just some scottish fairy tale
born out of boredom and too much single
malt whiskey the strange goings-on at
overtune bridge are a matter of public
record
mysterious doggy suicides have been
reported there since the 1950s
and the story has featured in major news
outlets including the independent and
the new york times
so just what the hell is going on here
i'd like to take a quick minute to talk
about hair loss because i've had people
close to me start to lose their hair as
early as their 20s
and it's always been an obsessing
experience
so if you're in the same boat then
you're not alone did you know two out of
three guys will experience some form of
male pattern baldness by the time
they're 35
but the best thing you can do to prevent
hair loss is take the initiative now and
do something about it whilst you've
still got hair left i like keeps because
it makes treatment super easy by
delivering your hair loss medication
every three months so you can say
goodbye to awkward doctor visits and
waiting in pharmacy checkout lines
there's a reason that keeps has more
five-star reviews than any of its
competitors and hundreds of thousands of
men trust them for their hair loss
prevention medication if you're like me
you're probably not ready to lose your
hair just yet but prevention is key the
faster you act the faster you'll see
results and the sooner you start using
keeps the more hair you'll save
so if you're noticing that you're losing
your hair do something about it for a
limited time go to keeps.com
42 or click the link in the description
to receive 50
off your first order
built in 1862 by wealthy lawyer and
businessman james white overtune house
is a grand old place you might actually
have already have heard of it or at
least already seen it it was used in the
filming of cloud atlas a film based on
the book of the same name by british
author david mitchell the bridge was a
later edition built in 1895 to connect
the original estate with a newly
acquired patch of land on the other side
of a gully carved out by the overtune
bridge to the untrained eye overtune
bridge looks pretty normal actually it
looks pretty normal to the trained eye
too but clearly our canine friends are
seeing something we aren't because
according to some sources as many as 600
dogs have inexplicably jumped off
overtune bridge over the last 70 years
or so leading to at least 50 doggy
fatalities and a small army of
traumatized owners
the question is
why do they jump considering what i've
just told you you won't be surprised to
learn that overtune bridge has earned
itself the highly creative nickname of
dog suicide bridge but
are these dogs really deliberately
trying to end their own lives the short
answer is
probably not
scientists aren't actually sure if it's
even possible for animals to commit
suicide plenty of species exhibit
self-destructive behavior
malaysian worker ants literally blow
themselves up when their colony comes
under threat honeybees die when they use
their sting on any animal with
relatively thick skin and there are
plenty of stories of dogs starving
themselves to death after their owners
die but whilst all those examples may
sound quite a lot like suicide
there's one key aspect of each that's
rather difficult to assess
intent
when a malaysian worker ant goes nuclear
in the general direction of its foes
it's probably acting on a base instinct
rather than some kind of utilitarian
belief in nobly sacrificing itself for
the greater good and the same goes for
honeybees and their stings even when it
comes to higher animals things are far
from clear does the dog who stops eating
when his owner dies know that doing so
will result in its death or is not
eating simply an instinctive reaction to
extreme stress nobody knows for sure and
without the intent to die
seemingly suicidal behavior
isn't actually suicide
at least not in a technical sense the
good news is we probably don't have to
worry too much about wrestling with the
philosophical scientific and linguistic
complexities of the overtune bridge case
after all it does seem quite unlikely
that all the suicidal dogs in britain
just happen to live in and around the
village of milton in southwest scotland
not to mention the fact that if
self-destruction really was the aim here
you'd think the dogs might have thought
to choose a more suitable location
overtune bridge is only about 15 meters
high and the majority of doug survived
the ordeal but whatever the motive the
dogs are definitely jumping
so if not suicide
what
this being scotland which i've already
mentioned is a decidedly magical place
by all accounts
plenty of people have considered shall
we say
unconventional explanations
some claim overtune bridge spans a
so-called thin place
where different realities bleed into our
own something our canine companions
apparently aren't big fans of others put
the dog deaths down to mischievous
spirits usually the conveniently local
white lady of overtune the ghost of a
woman who lived alone in overtune house
for 30 years after the death of her
husband the minor issue with both of
these theories of course is that they're
absolutely ridiculous i mean seriously
whatever your beliefs relating to all
things supernatural it seems a bit of a
stretch that we have a mass murdering
ghostly dog hater to blame for this
mystery or the lung
one theory that briefly seemed promising
was that some kind of ultrasonic sound
something only dogs could hear was to
blame the uk's trident nuclear-powered
submarines are housed in the naval base
at nearby faslane bay
and it was thought that perhaps this
mysterious noise came from somewhere
over in that direction but acoustic
experts have ruled this one out after
extensive testing at the bridge the
truth is to this day
nobody knows for sure what exactly is
going on at overtune bridge
the whole thing really is a genuine
unsolved mystery but there is one theory
that does a pretty good job of
explaining all the peculiarities of the
case
well
almost all of them but i'll get to that
in a minute
first we need to examine a few important
clues
clue number one
overtune bridge spans a steep gorge and
is surrounded with high vegetation on
all sides clue number two
being part of a lovely country estate in
scotland this area is teeming with local
wildlife including mice squirrels and
most importantly
mink clue number three
the walls that run the length of the
bridge are made of solid stone
and the top sections taper ever so
slightly down towards the drop below so
any ideas
well if you figure this out already then
congratulations you're basically the
jonathan creek of the dog world if not
then let me give you another clue
have you ever seen one of those memes
where some unexpecting guy jumps into
what looks to be a small puddle only to
be buried over his head in a deep pool
of muddy water that sort of thing
happens when our senses trickles into
thinking one thing when the reality of
this situation is very different
and it may be that from a dog's
perspective
overtune bridge works a little bit like
that because the key to this little
mystery lies in the unique way that dogs
perceive our world
as you're no doubt aware dogs have a
quite remarkable sense of smell we
humans have roughly 6 million olfactory
receptors in our noses to help us smell
the world around us
dogs on the other hand have around 300
million not only that but they dedicate
around 40 percent more of their total
brain power to processing smells than
humans do as a result the average dog
has a sense of smell that's up to 100
000 times more accurate than our own
when strolling across overtune bridge a
human might notice a few faint earthy
scents wafting in from the nearby fields
but a dog making that same crossing
would experience a veritable explosion
of complex smells the scents left behind
by other dogs
food cooking up at overtune house
dust drifting down off the old stones of
the bridge but
above all of that olfactory noise to a
dog one smell would stick out above all
of us the delicious sweet irresistible
scent
of mink piss
because it turns out that dogs for some
reason go absolutely bonkers for the
stuff
remember how i mentioned that multiple
dog owners have described their canine
companions suddenly stopping whilst
crossing over tomb bridge before a
malicious energy compels them to jump
that behavior sounds undeniably creepy
when viewed through the lens of dogs
mysteriously killing themselves
but switch up the context and it's
actually perfectly normal anyone who's
ever owned a dog will be familiar with
the sight of their beloved pets pausing
briefly whilst out on a walk before
suddenly pelting off into the
undergrowth after some unseen animal or
other
it may simply be that dogs crossing over
tomb bridge are picking up on the scent
of the nearby mink and bolting off to
try and murder them
that might not sound like a particularly
convincing explanation to begin with why
don't the dogs just walk down into the
gorge the old-fashioned way but
here's where overtune bridge's unusual
layout comes into play as per clue
number three
the walls that run along the sides of
the bridge are made from solid unbroken
stone
from a human perspective that detail is
essentially irrelevant
but for dogs whose eyes are set much
closer to the ground it's crucial in
combination with all the high vegetation
that surrounds the bridge on all sides
you're left with a kind of
dog's eye view optical illusion that
tricks passing canines into thinking
they're walking alongside a regular wall
with solid ground on the other side
rather than a precipitous 15 meter drop
the fact that the top of the wall is
tapered slightly downwards is the final
nail in the coffin because it makes it
that much harder for a dog jumping onto
the wall to arrest its momentum when its
eyes delivered the bad news that the
ground is 15 meters further down than
expected
it's a neat little theory that's made
even more convincing by the fact that
mink are thought to have first arrived
in the area in the 1950s
right around the time the first doggy
deaths were reported
there is one minor problem though
think about it there are thousands of
bridges in scotland and god knows how
many tens of thousands across the uk
so
why is this only happening at overtune
plenty of other bridges are lined with
solid walls and high vegetation isn't
exactly uncommon in this green and
pleasant land
minks are admittedly non-native to these
shores having come here from fur farms
in the u.s in the first half of the 20th
century
but it's safe to say the invasion has
been a resounding success
because as of today you can find those
smelly little buggers pretty much
everywhere combine that with the fact
that around a third of british
households are home to at least one dog
and it becomes very hard to believe that
the conditions at overtune bridge
aren't to be found anywhere else in the
country
and yet only at overtune bridge are dogs
leaping to their deaths in large numbers
until someone can explain that little
conundrum it's hard to say for sure that
the whole stinky mink optical illusion
theory is accurate
yeah we probably need to come up with a
better name for that okay
one final twist to this strange little
tale before i leave you and fair warning
this part is pretty unpleasant you see
it turns out that it isn't only dogs
that have fallen to their deaths from
overtoon bridge in 1994 a young father
threw his infant son from the bridge
after becoming convinced the child was
the incarnation of the devil
tragically that fall proved fatal
to this day plenty of people report
feeling a strange sense of foreboding
when crossing over tombridge
not just tin foil hat types either even
a few skeptics have confessed to feeling
a little uncomfortable there
for reasons they can't entirely explain
is that the result of the bridge's
sinister reputation getting to work on
their subconscious minds
or did i dismiss those unconventional
theories
a little too soon
i'll let you be the judge of that
thanks for watching